[Music]
my name is Jeremy no Meyer I'm a
developer advocate for IBM I work for a
center called the Center for open source
data and AI technologies and I'll talk a
little bit about our mission there and
it's an honor to be here the last time I
was here I was still in graduate school
studying biophysics my advisor was a
graduate of Columbia and we collaborated
with Columbia on a lot of research
projects so back the last time I was
here was back in graduate school so it's
it's really great to be back and he's a
beautiful campus so just a little bit
about me I started out as I mentioned
not in the area of computer science how
I actually started out as a chemical
engineer eventually got into biophysics
program did sort of computational
biophysics so I learned how to program
solving biochemistry problems and got
more interested in the computing side of
it than the biochemistry side of it and
eventually sort of reshaped my education
around that ended up landing at Lawrence
Livermore labs where they have the great
big some supercomputers and started to
do high-performance computing there and
and then did some programming with some
GPU accelerated molecular dynamics code
at Stanford but eventually with all of
that sort of the high-performance
computing version of Big Data training I
kind of retooled it using in a bootcamp
called the insight data science program
and it's a wonderful program there are
also many others that you know you can
get into to kind of specialize your
training for for the private sector and
this is like a about a 6-week boot camp
and then you get it get it back in
California you do a tour of tour of like
the Silicon Valley companies as part of
the interview process so it's really
great a really great journey but the
idea
behind all that as you know we don't all
come with a full tool kit to to solve
all the problems that you may encounter
but we need to you know it's nice to
have a place to start
have-have have an idea of you know if i
just had to pick a few things to learn
to call myself a data scientist what
would they be and so so Riley contacted
me and we worked out this book here it's
just a little hundred page less than 100
page text it's freely downloadable if
you go here and and download it and it
just kind of walks you through how to
get started in some of the frameworks
that we think are some of the you know
just the basic ones to get you up and
running and the all the notebooks are in
this github here and then finally I'll
walk you through we have a what's called
a free hosted notebook environment just
as just a show of hands when I say
Jupiter notebooks how many people are
familiar with those okay great great and
so we have a hosted notebook environment
that you know provides all kinds of nice
runtimes gpu-accelerated around time
SPARC runtimes and things like that so
if you go there and sign up there then
we can then I can tell them that that
you guys stumbled across it based on
based on this conference so I'll get to
come back this is one of my favorite
current conferences to come to so I'd
love to be able to come back so and then
we also have a lot of tensorflow all the
examples I'm going to walk through lots
of notebook examples today and these are
all just in a box folder that you can
download using that link right there so
if you want to follow along please feel
free so the idea is you know if you want
to go from like zero to hero here what
would what would it take to learn and we
definitely you know strongly advocate
for the use of the notebook environment
and so and you know for a while there
there were many notebook environments
that were out there Zeppelin was was a
prominent a prominent contender but you
know Jupiter's sort of emerged as the
most robust notebook and the developer
ecosystem is just enormous so so so we
sort of advocate for that within the
notebook and you know there are you can
run virtually any kernel you like you
can run scala you can rent or you can
we're in Python clearly and so so so
it's worth you know kind of working out
all the details of getting all that to
work if you're going to do distributed
machine learning you know we think
Apache spark is the one to learn and
that'll give you access to you know all
kinds of libraries that would otherwise
require separate installations and so so
if you you can you can sort of see
pretty much any kind of data big data
application from within an apache spark
context so it's definitely worth
learning and then you know apache spark
will start to run aground as you start
to require GPU resources because it's
mostly a java based environment so so
there's lots and lots of GPU accelerated
deep learning environments but
tensorflow
tends to be the one that people really
favor again the developer ecosystem is
enormous right now it's got something
like 41 million downloads at this point
one of the largest projects ever to be
available in the open communities so so
it's really great so again you know just
to stump a little bit for this notebook
thing it's not just the developers that
get to use these things it's everybody
in the organization and it really has
been adopted company-wide for lots of
big companies like Bloomberg Netflix
there's a bunch of other companies that
are really just kind of taking it across
the board and this means that everybody
from technical leadership to legal teams
to management everybody is sort of
communicating through these notebook
environments so it's kind of fun you
know as a data scientist to kind of
fiddle with this stuff and get get to
learn these things but it's also now a
pretty widely accepted medium of
communication can be included as an
appendix if in a publication and and you
know you can always run live code in it
so it's really great
um and you know just to just to kind of
remind you know of ourselves of you know
what iBM has has done in terms of its
history with open-source and this really
started with the Linux project this was
back when there were a whole slew of
operating systems lots of proprietary
UNIX environments in estas was coming
out and Linda's Torvalds said hey you
know I kinda wanna do this open-source
kernel thing maybe we can kind of have
this you know organically grown Linux
environment where people contribute as
needed to make the kernel robust and
they said okay IBM so IBM got involved
with this and said okay we'll create
something called the Linux Technology
Center and the mission of and the
mission of any of these technology
centers that IBM creates is to you know
promote the use of an open-source
project within the IBM community and
then also across all the communities
that are involved so we can have shared
interests in these and so we were one of
the original founders of the Apache
foundation the Linux Foundation we also
created something called the Java
Technology Center the Java technology
Center resulted in the development of an
IDE called the Eclipse project was about
a 50 million dollar investment and they
released that into the open community
and made it freely available and then
since then we've been pretty much
involved in all of the open source
projects that have that have really come
into being try to get in on the ground
floor and get involved in the open
governance side of it so that we can
influence the project and and then so
Apache spark we were we were involved
with it when it was still a university
project and some of the other ones there
so the you know is we're also really
involved in in you know the idea of an
open standard so we have this predictive
mark model markup language the open
network open neural network exchange
format we're also not only involved in
data
formats but actual data provenance so we
have something called the data asset
exchange where we make sure that the
data that's being released has correct
lineage and and is usable you know if
you wanted to use it to train models
that were gonna be used for commercial
applications is it is that data okay to
use and things like that so so the idea
is you know a rising tide lifts all
boats and you know just to remind us of
what the power of these open-source
projects are you know the Linux project
resulted in you know the founding of Red
Hat we acquired Red Hat for thirty four
billion dollars and that company had
absolutely no IP so you know open source
is really a viable way of building the
code and probably the best way to
develop these large projects so the
center that I belong to is this Center
for open source data in AI technology
and that so our our job is to advocate
for AI frameworks which includes all of
the deep learning frameworks big data
frameworks which is things like Apache
spark and various open source projects
that kind of belong to that ecosystem so
I I wanted to just point you to how many
people are familiar with deep learning
applications in general like what deep
learning is capable of how many people
are sort of new to deep learning and ok
so so we've got a little little of both
this if you are relatively new to deep
learning maybe or maybe even know what
the fundamental how the fundamentals
look and you want to see what the
applications look like this is a great
little sampler of docker images that you
can just download and then just run and
then they'll present to a rest endpoint
and then you could submit images and it
will do object detection for example so
it's very easy so within you know within
less than a minute you can you can get
any of these up and running and you can
see what they can do and give yourself
an afternoon and you can really have a
good survey of the field and the
applications that are available all free
all open-source most of it's built on
tensorflow there are other ones that are
built on cafe and PI torch and things
like that so this is actually a
framework
gnostic exchange but i do in general
like to at least touch on the very very
basics of neural networks just so we
have common language and then we'll get
into some examples and we talked a
little bit about it but the just the
basic idea of a neural network is you've
got a neuron here in and so really all
the neuron it is is is it takes an input
and transforms it into an output and so
it's a it's a function and that function
takes this z value which is the sum of
features times weights plus a bias so
the features are the inputs the weights
are these parameters that we have to
discover through certain through
numerical optimization and the bias is
also a parameter and so that number gets
fed into this activation function this
activation function takes on various
forms and one of the forms one of the
most common forms is a logistic form the
idea is is that it has its in a
continuous approximation to a step
function because a neuron is supposed to
be you know either on or off at some
point it hits a threshold and it fires
and so we try to replicate that that
effect with this logistic function that
you know has goes from zero to one it
has a sort of saturation feature in
practice that does not always result in
the best numerical properties when
you're trying to optimize the function
so so we usually do something called the
rectified linear unit which is this
function down here and this function
here has slightly better gradient
properties because then it doesn't
saturate at one in which you know you
have this this problem called the
gradient vanishing problem which makes
for different creates two numerical
difficulties so you either have
something that's like a logistic
function maybe towards the output and
then and then all of the internal layers
tend to have these rectified linear
units for the activation functions and
so these neurons are almost always
arranged in this this dense layer
arrangement they don't have to be
but it turns out that this is sort of
the common language that people people
use when they describe this and so
really what they do is you just have one
layer of neurons and then you have
another layer of layer of neurons and
then layer one is only connected to
layer two it's not connected to any
other layers in front of it or behind it
in in principle it could be and actually
as we'll see in some of the even the
Charis API supports really complex
topologies but in general you just it's
it's it's much easier to think of these
things as just a collection of layers
that are connected by these dense
weights and so if you think of any kind
of supervised learning algorithm is that
you have a set of features which is
which is called X and then you have an
output which is called Y what you do
when you train a supervised learning
algorithm as you feed it a label which
is the Y value then you feed it the
feature which is the x value or the X
vector and you do that lots and lots of
times and the then you discover the
parameters for that particular function
well that's all that's happening here
this is a supervised learning algorithm
you're feeding it a bunch of features
you for me and then you're getting a
bunch of outputs and then your your
training based on that in this case the
output is a category so the category can
be one of ten possible categories
because this turns out to be the Amnesty
Attah set which just goes from zero to
nine and the input is this unwrapped
image so you just take the image and you
unwrap it and now it's a feature vector
and then you feed that into the input
layer so the input layer is the one that
takes in the features the output layer
is the result so if this were just a
simple function it would just have the
input layer and the output layer but the
fact that it has these other layers in
the middle it adds these hidden layers
which gives the network depth the depth
is where we get the deep learning part
so all of these internal layers is
really what gives improves the
performance of these predictions in ways
that we
we just can't see using these just the
simple input/output so the real advance
the reason why we call the deep learning
is the the real advance was we developed
the you know numerical algorithms and
all of the approaches and the hardware
started to catch up that allowed us to
compute these networks that had these
internal layers for a longest time we
really couldn't get him to those numbers
to converge based on the way we were
opinion and a lot of it was you know we
weren't using back propagation properly
we were using the right activation
functions and and then the hardware just
just wasn't there at the time and so so
now all that seems to be in place and
now it seems to be really this guy seems
to be the limit the only real limitation
is now computing capacity and it's you
know there's open there's been openly
released trained models that have a
billion and a half parameters for these
neural networks so they you know it's
just really a it's really mind-boggling
how far it's come in terms of the
robustness and so last time I was at
data council in San Francisco we were
working on this recurrent neural network
model so I just thought I'd throw it in
there just just this just to remind you
that these neurons can be that simple
activation form but they can also have a
slightly more complex form and so this
is what's called an LS TM unit and this
is basically a neuron that has lots of
lots of internal parameters that allow
you to call it multiple times so that
you have a what's called a persistent
state for each neuron and that allows
you to do things like time series
modeling and other things so basically
you take this neural net you take one of
these neurons and you just call it
multiple times every time you call it it
will emit a slightly different state and
so this allows you to do things like
text processing and and voice-to-text
kind of things and another sort of time
series modeling kinds of things just
started included because it's actually a
pretty fun project and you have you can
do things like these encoder decoder
models where you can model multivariate
time series disome can be constructed in
Kerris so it's completely accessible
I went to jump in and sort of talk about
what tensor how many people are familiar
with the tensor flow project okay great
okay so so it's yeah it's a simple
Python API for running GPU accelerated
tensor calculations and really it wasn't
it was originally written just to be a
you know Python API in the in sort of
the same way the MATLAB was originally
written to be an API to the lay pack
library this was written to be kind of
an API to the to the GPU accelerated
calculations and then they wanted to
have tensor capabilities because they
wanted to have more than just two
dimensions so numpy arrays are
two-dimensional and then tensor tensors
are you know an arbitrary number of
dimensions and then they can run on GPUs
that was the basic idea is just to get
get these calculations to run on on the
GPU so you can solve partial
differential equations you can do all
kinds of fancy stuff if you get down to
the to the tensorflow api but in general
the Charis api is what's preferred
Kerris is actually not it's it's just a
specification it's just a way of the way
of defining these neural networks so
they created he created this in Python
so that you could write neural networks
and now the new version of tensorflow
has much tighter integration with Kerris
and you very rarely need to use the the
actual tensorflow lower-level tensorflow
operations it does distributed
calculations which means you can
distribute your calculation over one CPU
multiple GPUs multiple CPUs multiple
CPUs with multiple GPUs and all of that
kind of combination I don't think that
it does like node to node communication
this is like ideally on all all on one
chip but there are libraries that allow
for MPI communication I came a horrified
I think it was a goober project or
something along those lines that allows
for the really scalable deep learning
compute but it also has lots and lots of
edge computing capabilities so I do have
some examples
I have lots of examples so if you guys
want to uh sure me too one example or
the other make sure you you know raise
your hand let me know what's going on
the so we've got an in-browser in
browser JavaScript API called tensorflow
j-p-j s which allows you to run models
allows you to train models and it runs
on all kinds of anything that supports
JavaScript and it's really great because
don't have to deal with any kind of
installation issues you can do mobile
deployment with tensorflow light and
then you can also there's another even
lighter weight version a tensorflow
light called into flow micro which which
will allow you to deploy on these things
called DSPs with models that have you
know kilobyte footprints you can deploy
Raspberry Pi and actually we actually
have spent a little bit of time doing
the Raspberry Pi Raspberry Pi work you
do pip3 installation you can do the full
installation and run it you can also run
tensorflow light on Raspberry Pi and and
and get better performance but you know
if you want to do kind of development
prototyping you can deploy the full
tensorflow
version on Raspberry Pi we also have
this how many people are familiar with a
node-red project
anybody ever ever heard of that ok no no
dread is a visual is a visual interface
to node J s and it's really cool it
there's we have people that advocate for
this and it's it's completely
open-source and you can run node-red
on Raspberry Pi and then it's like drag
and drop stuff where you can get all of
your your nodejs
type applications running and then you
can also run tensorflow from within that
it tends to float you can run tens of a
light and anyway so tensorflow 2.0 is is
the new standard we've been really
trying to get people to adopt this back
when it was in alpha because it has lots
of API breaking changes and I had to
potentially have that Python 2 to Python
3 kind of
and so we really want to say hey if
you're gonna start writing this stuff
write it in tensorflow 2.0 it's really
this will be the stable API for moving
forward and and I you know the other
thing that's really great about this is
it just has just running you know
tensorflow 2.0 out-of-the-box on
whatever regardless of hardware
configuration get a to 3x bump and
efficiency so it's they did lots and
lots of work to make this a really high
performance and they've added profiling
tools and some other things but some of
the some of the sort of bigger ones is
they have this thing called TF data
which is this API for easy input
management again you get performance
increases if you use this API now you
call Karis through TF Kara's and it's
got a lot tighter integration tensorflow
hub is now sort of up and running very
robust now you can do things like you
know transfer learning as well as pre
trained models one of the big ones is
eager execution if how many people are
familiar with the one dot X API okay so
that was it sometimes you know lazy
evaluation is kind of hard to get your
head around especially when you're
running stuff in Python and you expect
to see results right away but but now it
supports eager executions so the
development cycle for the debug cycle is
usually a little quicker for exploratory
work it has a much better distributed
strategy built into it now and it has a
few standards a shion's
which are you know there are again there
are other standard models out there like
the onyx file format and and other and
other formats for neural networks
tensorflow standard model is going to be
this saved model and this this saved
model now allows you to export it all
across you know back and forth to the
JavaScript version back and forth the
tensorflow light so within the
tensorflow light ecosystem it's gives
you lots and lots of lots and lots of
options
and we you can expert to save model it
they've also released a fairness library
which I haven't played with too much but
it it allows you to deal with things
like bias and your datasets and things
like that in a systematic way which in
which we're really excited about there's
this thing called the Linux Foundation
for fairness and AI and and and there
are lots of open-source libraries that
are supported based on that and and this
this looks like a great candidate for
that it also had you know so so now you
can launch tensor board from I'll do a
tensor board example where you can see
the tensor boat is running can be run in
the notebooks you can do tracing you can
do profiling you figure out what kind of
where we're where your code is running
and and you can do all that from within
your notebook
and then lots and lots of really cool
edge and IOT computing applications
coming out so all the JavaScript stuff
is great tensorflow light is getting
much much better there's lots of tight
cup of Google and arm are working very
closely together to to to get lots of
these tensorflow light applications
working on on their chips and then we
have the the micro which is the really
really lightweight tensorflow tensorflow
footprint so here's the link to the
notebooks that I'll be kind of walking
through and how we doing for time so so
I just I'm going to jump into some
examples here and the first one I wanted
to do is just show you what the the
hosted environment looks like because if
you've never I mean it's a it's a great
experience to get you know to do all the
installed KU libraries and get all this
working on on on hardware from scratch
but we have a hosted environment that
allows you to to do that and this hosted
environment is so this is a this is a
this is a basically a jupiter notebook
that is hosted through
through our cloud service and you can
run the you can run Python code and a
bunch of other kernels but what's nice
about it is you can pick your you can
pick your environment pretty
transparently so you just do a drop-down
and then we've got a GPU v100 that's
available here you've got spark
environments you've got all these other
ones so doing some GPU doing some quick
GPU calculations this is a pretty handy
way to do it and you just a little bit
of boilerplate to get the get the code
running and then you can see that we're
running tensorflow too and whereas the
it's got the nvidia SMI that you can run
to make sure it's actually running on a
on a GPU and then then also you can
check to see that that the device is
hooked up so right now you kind of have
to get he still kind of have to do a
little bit of manual manual work to get
this hooked up properly because we're
we're we're providing the 1x GPU
environment sorted out of the box but
you got to do a little bit of wrangling
because this has only been released for
a month less than a month but it's
pretty straightforward to get it get it
up and running so if you're interested
let me know and I'll be happy to show
you how to do that
I just want to walk you through the
overview of some of the changes so let's
go back let's go to the top here and
it's a quick quick overview so you do
PIPP installed tensorflow
2.0 so this is the layers library that
allows you to create this neural network
sequentially so start out with the entry
point with the first layer which is the
dense layer at another layer on right on
right next to that and then finally add
the output layer which has got ten
categories and you know and engine you
know it's a categorical output because
they they like to use this thing called
the softmax which sort of preferentially
it returns a normalized vector with it
kind of preferentially selects one
category and doesn't give you a broad
distribution of categories so you can
configure the layers and then this is
another way of constructing the neural
network and finally you can do train and
evaluate so once you create these models
the next thing you're going to do is
you're going to compile the models with
add your optimizer so this is this is
the Adam optimizers for the stochastic
gradient like optimizer and since this
is a category level one you're going to
create a loss function called
categorical cross entropy that tends to
favor your categorical ones there's
another one if you're doing a regression
it's the mean squared error I came here
Amin accumulated or k-member which one
it is and and then the metrics the
metrics here that you want to track or
accuracy and that those metrics will
allow you that you can you can trace
during the during the optimization
procedure and then you can also look at
it using tensor board and go ahead and
compile it and then you have this model
summary which gives you just gives you
you know basically tells you what you
created you created these dents
layers and the total number of
parameters and we have to skip some of
this some on some of this stuff doesn't
quite work we can run a training model
here I don't know the fit so this is the
data sets API that I was telling you
about this one is just a little bit more
efficient again you know I'm presenting
this is a lot of boilerplate but this
boilerplate it's pretty easy to transfer
into your own workflow so I'm going to
provide it for you the so the data set
here is now you create the batch size as
part of the definition of the dataset
and and then you and then you just still
pick your app box as part of the fitting
process but this in general will run
much much faster see maybe we might even
be able to take a look at let's see 6
milliseconds per step versus yeah it's
not comparable predict ok so these are
the advanced models that I was talking
about so now you can use the Charis API
to kind of pull out bits and pieces of
your network and sort of use them and
and so you can create this this dense
layer and now this dense layer can
actually be used in multiple networks so
you just have this other dense layer as
a function of the input layer so then
you can you know this is something like
transfer learning where you can kind of
pull out chunks of neural networks and
putting right you can do this with the
Charis and I'm not sure you could do
this with Karis before but but the
integration is much much tighter now so
you really you know you know even for
the fancy stuff you really don't need to
get dope go beyond the kara CPI and they
they do recommend using Karis for the
most part there is this and there's kind
of mixed reviews on whether this on best
practices for this there are folks that
really are into writing at creating a
model as a class for whatever reason if
it integrates better into their code or
if they
like the the idea of it I've heard
recommendations that say maybe maybe
stick with the Karis API if you can but
you can write the you can write a class
directly and you can have you know
access to kind of lower-level things
even maybe even even more low-level than
something like this and you can save the
class so you can once you create the
model as a class you can save it and
persist the model and the topology
that's generated by that class and
recover the topology so it's it's an
interesting it's an interesting addition
and then we can do custom layers so the
other thing in it and I can't remember
if this was in part of one dot X or not
but they have a thing called a callback
and the most common thing that a call to
a callback is something that really
rapport is a kind of a reporter that is
given during the optimization procedure
and this callback here is really the one
that you see most is the early stopping
one so basically you it just prevents
from overtraining so you know you know
that in general these optimization
functions start out or the loss function
starts out very large and then drops
very rapidly and then it kind of
flattens out and then so there's a kind
of a you don't get much bang for your
buck for the at some point for running
excess of optimizations and you know GPU
cycles can add up so you want to have an
early stopping monitor and so that's
what that's what this callback allows
you to do so it's an important it's an
important feature to be able to have
access to saving and restoring is
there's a whole variety of ways to do
that and really you know we just want to
make sure that we point you to these
examples of how they can be done you can
save the weights you can load the
weights you can also you can do in JSON
format you can do it
and you can import it and export it you
can persist it from the JSON string
create a Hamel string and create the
fresh model for their mom
now you can so there's the idea if you
got the configuration and then you've
got the weights the configuration is
something that can be loaded and then
you can just update the weights and just
load reload the weights or you can save
the entire model needs to call it a
frozen graph you can do that as an h5
format or another format that's also
commonly uses the protobuf format where
it's kind of all compressed into one so
all of that is available and then this
is the eager execution that we discussed
and then this is this is what the you
know the I think that the way that they
wrote the distribution strategies for
multiple GPUs is very very elegant and
easy to easy to implement so this really
is what it would look like before if you
didn't have it distributed and now as
you do is just put this with strategy
dot scope you create this strategy and
then you're you've got mirrored strategy
and then you got this if you're having
multiple CPUs it's called multi worker
marriage strategy and it's um it's
pretty straightforward to to to
generalize it to multiple GPUs so and
then you can just do the same and then
the rest of your code looks pretty much
the same so that's the over that's kind
of the you know that's something that
really covers a lot of the you know the
sent the the syntax kind of things that
you're going to see in the tensorflow 2o
api all the kind of functionality so how
we doing on time I can jump into a few
more minutes okay so I'm thinking I can
maybe I'll show you very quickly there
are some text processing examples here
that I'd be happy to show you I can show
you the EM nest data set I've got I've
got the Emnes data set I've got I've got
a tensor board example and then I've got
a JavaScript example as well as a
iPhone example so as we kind of move
into questions just somebody raise your
hand say I want to see that example or
something like that and we'll just you
know where it's more interested I can
you know could jump into there I think
we have until what 2:45 is so yeah just
feel free to kind of you know let me
know what what you guys are interested
in so I will just show you very briefly
with the basic classification algorithm
how many people are familiar with the
the fashion m ness dataset okay all
right okay so this is just you know this
is basically the same thing as the in
this dataset which was the postal
employees number handwritten number data
set and this one here is just the same
thing it's just now it's clothes instead
of numbers and so it has ten categories
these are the categories here and this
is a guy this is a really nice example
because it it's a canonical supervised
learning algorithm and it really shows
you how to get to all of the pieces of
of all of the bits of data that are
floating around in this and you know
just create create these you know and
then now it has a shape for the images
the number of labels is the number of
training labels is here and so you've
got labels and images the shape of the
images is a 28 by 28 each one is a 28 by
28 pixel image and then you can
pre-process the data this is what the
image looks like do some normalization
for the images and then you can generate
a set of figures for that just to show
you what they look like
create your layer and you're gonna
flatten your input vector it's a 28 by
28 images and then it's gonna be what
784 7 64 that's going to be the vector
that goes in to and that then you begin
your training based on that the output
is going to be so the inner layer is
going to have the value or
the input layers gonna have the rail you
function and the output layer is gonna
have the softmax function and and then
you compile it fit it and value with the
accuracy and then just shows you how to
get to you know where the test labels
are the predictions are this is some
plotting and this is just one of the
predictions so it has a 94% prediction
that it's an ankle boot and then it's
the distribution of the output so those
that this histogram here is the output
layer values you can see here that it
thinks it's a sneaker but it also kind
of thinks I think it's a sandal so you
start to see some of these more
ambiguous and I mean now I can now you
can see what the prediction is and then
you can see the distribution of the
neuron layers this is one of the this is
this is probably one of my favorite
examples because it allows you to get
into the guts of it was simple
matplotlib plotting and have to do
anything really fancy and you can see
how you can get the really good sense of
what the data structures are like and if
you're comfortable with coding and
python and you're comfortable numpy
arrays and map plot live and all that
this will come very naturally to you so
it's a great place to start and and
here's that so that that's pretty much
that one I think maybe I'll just if I
can take a pause here and see if there's
any questions and if not I can jump into
another example or I can go ahead and
wrap up okay great yeah so I do have
office hours and I can walk you through
some of those examples there if you guys
are interested but in the meantime yeah
thanks for having me if there's any
questions
[Applause]
[Music]